numbers in last month's job report the  nation's unemployment rate is still high  sitting at 6 percent right now about 2.4  million americans have been without work  for at least a year  the bureau of labor statistics says  about 1.6 million people  were without a job in march of 2021  compared to march of 2020  while unemployment is high local resort  companies are hiring now to try and meet  the increasing demand  caesars entertainment for example says  it needs to fill 200 guest room  attendant positions  immediately and you can interview for  one of those jobs tomorrow from nine  until  two just apply online first at the  caesars website  the company plans to hire people right  on the spot  now we've put together a list here at  eight news now of several companies  across the valley in southern nevada  that are hiring  just head to eight newsnow dot com click  on the job board tab and hopefully find  some work